check out the story we got from the
philadelphia inquirer
this is look
this is this story is a level of
deranged
nothing i'm going to read the quote this
is the title nothing is more important
than team trump's january powerpoint
urging a full-blown coup the scariest
part about trump's coo plot including a
banana republic style national emergency
is that the conspiracy is still
happening
is it
the philadelphia inquirer a mainstream
publication is outright telling the
people of this country namely
philadelphia but also the country that
there is a current ongoing donald trump
conspiracy to take over the country
now what do you think that's going to do
to someone's mind you get the new york
times saying the white supremacists are
coming for you they're gonna they're
gonna target especially liberal women
it's almost like they're trying
themselves to target liberal women with
fear to make them lose their minds
and i'll tell you something interesting
too
women in suburban women in virginia
voted for yunkan they voted republican
clearly suburban women do not like
donald trump
now you have the philadelphia inquirer
saying the conspiracy with trump is
still happening it's a full-blown
military coup and here's the proof
these people live in
a very twisted version it's like a
bizarro world cliques
if they do won't that make them so
here's my theory
there are people who are finally over
covered they're done with the fear
factor of it
so what do you get in place of it
civil war
coup
trump takeover of the country i i
disagree man i i i partly agree i think
there's a craving for like like the
media is like what can we pump up
but back in 2018 i said if what we're
seeing with the street fighting across
the country popping up all over the
place continues then i think we are
heading towards some kind of civil war i
don't know exactly how that will
manifest but people make the mistake of
believing it's going to be a mason-dixon
line and the state's going like that it
could be something crazy i don't know
then in 2019 we saw you know more signs
of it it was back in 2018 these articles
popped up and then i started talking to
people and they were like you're crazy
that's the stupidest thing i've ever
heard that's i would have conservatives
in dc tell me that and i'm like what
makes you think it couldn't happen like
why do you have that optimism bias it'll
never happen here and the response i got
was
what's happening with antifa and proud
boys and right-wing groups and stuff is
is a bunch of low-level you know bored
losers fighting in the streets and it
will never reach the point at the seat
of government it will never be in the
federal government and the security
state will shut it down
now
we have
you know political like fighting between
you know the progressive wing and the
populist right-wing in congress threats
of arrest against some of them nancy
pelosi is saying some of them should be
investigated how many of them do you
think are feds
which ones all of them
yeah maybe a lot of
our congressmen you think they went
undercover and ran for office no i mean
like antifa probably i mean it's just
like how many of them tons of them but
so so so which is interesting but the
point was brought to me was the federal
government will never allow it to happen
and i'm like what happens when this
conflict reaches the federal government
if the millennial generation and younger
is divided to an extreme degree
and they are taking these seats of power
in 10 20 years millennials are going to
be the majority of like 80 90 of
congress
and that culture war is going to be in
congress it's going to be in the
president it's going to be in the senate
god
yeah right the congress will be
insufferable then yeah i mean it's not
insufferable now oh yeah let me get
buzzfeed let's go this is what this
congressman did
yeah but like
if if these people who genuinely believe
this stuff are in that seat of power
then it the culture war does reach the
government and then and then what
happens they get stripped of their power
no way who well no i think an angry mob
i think the culture will already reach
the federal government through trump
because he
he was very much
leading the charge
in that cultural war i mean as soon as
you had you know colin kaepernick kneel
uh during the national anthem trump took
that as an issue and boom as soon as he
said something about it in i think what
2018
then all of a sudden
it never left you're right
the culture war reaching the federal
government was the 2015 election cycle
before that we had you know what mitt
romney barack obama in 2012 and it was
very stodgy boring establishment
politics yeah but in 2015 the culture
war reached a point where people were
voting on this and it was the
establishment versus the
i guess the cultural independence the
trump people the the populists
well so
it used to be politics was a bunch of
stodgy boring you know the lesser of two
evils but then trump comes along and
he's like you know a bull gonna storm
through and smash everything up all of a
sudden now the seat of the federal
government was a culture war issue
now it's 20 20 we're entering 2022 how
crazy is that we got to call trump the
rhino in the china shop because he's a
rhino
and this is like he's a liberal guy
random the republican he's a rhino
republican i mean he's not really a
republican exactly no he's not true
i'm gonna call him the rhino trump is
trump is trump i mean
hey so here's here's what i will happen
to be a republican yeah this time are
next to his name we had um i think was
ryan long was here and i love ryan he's
great we you know the babies hate them
though they don't like him really he he
got he got he he threw a hard question
at me right when we started the show
he was like he's like so tim the last
time i was here he said a civil war was
coming you got me all freaked out and
then what's going on and then i went
on january 6th about 800 people stormed
into the capitol
and he went oh yeah
so i had all these people telling me
that nothing was going to happen we
weren't getting close to a civil war now
these establishment liberal types when
they say it to me i just do the same
thing they go where's civil war tim
on january 6 800 trump supporters
stormed into the like i don't know is
that enough for you i don't think it was
as bad as they say it was yeah for them
is it and they're like oh yeah and now
they're saying the coup is still
happening well that's the thing yeah
that's the thing i mean it's it's almost
like they just want to be right every
single time or they don't want to give
you a credit
i mean
i think maybe the reality is
like
how how how does this train stop
because there's like do the trump
supporters who are sitting sitting in
the prisons right now in the solitary
confinement do they get released and
then walk up to abiding supporter and
just cry and then hug and say it's
america damn it and like we don't want
this anymore
or do they say i was tortured
by his estab by his administration by
his doj
and then does this result in people
saying the system is corrupt
and the left is saying but they're
insurrectionists who should be honestly
i think a lot of it is even happening
now over a lot of these coveted
restrictions vaccine mandates mass
mandates there are odd strange there's
some strange bev fellows kind of working
together
on the left and right who oppose a lot
of these restrictions and
honestly that might not be enough to
heal the country but it's brought some
people together
i mean we've seen black lives matter
marching with right wing groups in new
york yeah saying opposing the vast
mandates but is it possible that that
actually is just part of
further decay of the system i mean you
don't have you don't have friends or
enemies you have common interests in
politics that's just how it's always
been and so
i mean they have common goals
and once they
say
accomplish that goal then they'll go
back to fighting each other so maybe
maybe that's the normal we're going back
to i think
if if we look if i try to look at this
optimistically like it's not going to
get that bad because something will
divert attention and the factions will
shift again before it gets too bad it
kind of just feels like you know the
swing is getting too far left too far
right and then eventually the swing is
too much and the tower topples over you
know what i mean yeah like right now
it's shaking we got a bad earthquake but
not enough to knock the the structure of
the united states down
but if it keeps happening and the the
swings get more and more extreme then
eventually the whole thing is going to
just implode on itself well the
conditions that are creating the
hyperbolic you know political moments
they're only increasing in their power
and influence if you look at big tech
it's only becoming more influential in
our lives if you look at the corporate
media it's being force-fed on us even
more those are the two biggest
contributors those are the gasoline on
the fire of this quiet cold civil war
that some people say is happening right
now and those two institutions are not
going away they're only becoming more
powerful and i think it's in their
interest to have people fighting each
other because they also represent a lot
of very powerful people and those
powerful people don't want them looking
up and recognizing that the true source
of their problems is the multinational
corporations is the billionaire class
that is able to buy off government buy
off big tech social media and it is them
fighting each other based off trivial
differences based off their dna their
preferences and if they can have people
fighting with the pitchforks against the
torches when they have those two people
going against each other no one's
focusing on any of the legitimate
problems that is directly affecting
their lives and and and how they live in
this existence but that just means that
eventually the system crumbles and the
elites escape with as much resources
exactly i mean the elites already have
have a huge have accumulated so much
resources so much money but but the
elites never historically understand
when enough is enough uh if if you look
at every time a country was was
was robbed of its wealth if you look at
all the hyperinflation cases whether
it's
weimar germany whether it's uh argentina
whether it's zimbabwe whether it's
venezuela it's always people saying this
is for me i don't care about anyone else
the rats are you know leaving here let's
plunder what we can that has always
happened through recorded human history
especially when you have a government
willing to increase the debt ceiling
increase the money printing increase
government programs that stand in the
way of free economic flow of income and
money and capital so this is only going
to get worse because of the financial
ramifications which i think are critical
here because that's going to be the
other kind of match you have the fuel by
by the the
corporate media the fuel by by the the
social media but the match i think is
going to be the financial larger
ramifications thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you